now one huge section of society that's
experienced big changes in their lives
over the last year
of course young people hit hard by the
closure of things like hospitality
venues as a source of work as well as
entertainment
and the unprecedented restrictions on
face-to-face teaching in schools
and universities plus all that followed
from that
in terms of social isolation and effects
on mental health well let's discuss all
those issues i'm joined now by
josephine helen who's 25 and is an actor
and singer and has launched her own
business during the pandemic
johnny jenkins he's 20 and is a third
year student at warwick university
and molly marvel who's 16 and is at
school
in year 11. thanks very much indeed for
for joining us lots to discuss but first
of all from all of you just a
just a short feeling on the fact that
you
are the generation who as we're going to
discuss have suffered an awful lot in so
many different ways
during the course of this pandemic by
and large though
to protect older people how do you feel
about that josephine
um i i think there's a lot of heaviness
around young people
i think as a result of this a lot of us
do feel very anxious
um so i think that's the main thing that
young people are feeling currently is
very anxious
johnny is it uh a sacrifice for you
that's been worth making
of course because these people who are a
little bit older and a little bit more
vulnerable
are our loved ones and so i am
completely comfortable with having made
sacrifices over the past year
it's not been easy it's not been fun all
the times
but young people aren't special we've
all been affected by the pandemic
and we're just one group of society
amongst many others
and molly you go along with that jo
we're all in it together
um i think it's been such like an
individual experience for everyone
but i think certainly it's been really
grounding and like taking a step back
and having time to re-evaluate
um i think it's just a really important
for all of us
okay well let's uh let's stay with you
molly i want to talk about your
individual experiences
um you're all experienced lockdowns in
different ways and molly uh so year 11
that means of course you had the last
couple of terms of year 10 disrupted and
and it goes on presumably um not sitting
gcses this year getting getting an
assessment or maybe your school is
giving you some exams tell us about it
so um they've said obviously the
government announced they were
exams were cancelled but our school has
decided that we're going to do
smaller scale tests in inside school
that's going to set our
grades for um for our gcses
and how has it been molly um all that
teaching and learning from home how have
you managed that
i mean me certainly i've i've much
preferred working from home because i
feel like once you take yourself out of
the school environment
you can just so much more um you know
you take a step back and you can say
hey i'm just like this is who i am and
these are the things i'm interested in
and to isolate that side of yourself
away from school
has been so beneficial especially for me
um
to see that it's not all about grades on
a piece of paper it's about
the education that you get from things
outside of school
and i think that's been really important
thing for everyone to realize
that um yeah that you can get this
distinction between
um you know those busy environments and
actually staying at home
so i think it's been a really good
experience for me very positive
johnny what's the university experience
been then what did i say uh third year
at
warwick so uh similar pattern then
different experience in terms of what
molly's been through
so your second year disrupted and now it
goes on through
virtually the entirety of your your
third year presumably you had a
a bit of face-to-face teaching a return
to campus to return to university at the
end of last year
at the end of last academic year no but
towards
the end of 2020 and before christmas i
had three months at university having
face-to-face teaching and that was
really good
a really fantastic experience but over
the past 12 months i've spent
just those three months um at university
the rest of it studying from home
this time last year i came home for the
easter break
uh to see my family here in south end in
essex
and i stayed here instead of for six
weeks for six months and
that was really difficult at first
having to adapt get my head around
what's
going on and how it's affecting us and
i've just
finished the second term of my final
year at university and that's all
been um at home as well it's it's been
difficult the education
isn't the same uh the teachers and the
lecturers are working incredibly hard to
try and
get a quality experience for us but no
matter how hard they try
um they just can't match that
face-to-face teaching so hopefully after
easter
when things lose a little bit i'll be
able to get back to university
and spend some of my last few weeks
face-to-face in the classroom
we really hope so so josephine acting
and singing well we know what's happened
to that over the last year would t
tell us about uh about that and and the
opportunity then you've taken out of it
do you see it as an opportunity you've
set up your own business
yeah so um almost overnight my whole
industry was shut down and as a
performer
you often work in bars and restaurants
and things like that so
your second part of income was
completely gone as well
so i'd kind of had this idea about my
business
starting anyway which is josephine
stories
and then when lockdown happened and i
had to move home which i was
very thankful to have my family there um
i was able to put a lot of time and to
start my own business
and we're actually one today one years
old and
i've achieved quite a lot on a year so
it's been a negative and a positive
process
ah one year older like the original
lockdown now
very good to hear that let me talk to
you though about i mean it's so
important
it's so important to everyone of course
not social interaction we've all
been missing but uh you are these
formative periods of your life
molly have you been able to keep in
touch with people and you know is that
affecting you you mentally a bit the
ways you've got to interact with your
friends
um so i think before lockdown started we
knew
that we were going to have to like adapt
to a different way of communicating with
each other and interacting with each
other
but i'm so lucky and i've got such a
supportive group of friends and we kept
in touch via
zoom like i am now um we kept in touch
um
by a social distance walks when we could
and i just think it's so nice that
people and families and everyone that i
know
like most everyone that i know has been
so supportive with them
and just knowing the importance of
keeping social communication as well as
everything else that's going on
johnny has it got you down a bit um the
lack of social interaction i mean
some people say particularly some
students say
the social side is as important as the
academic one
yeah a lot of people go to university
because they want to make friends and it
is a really big
part of it i think there is a positive
to take from it which is
those i've lived with my flatmates when
i was at university i've been able to
spend so much time with them and get to
know them even
better and at the moment i'm spending a
lot of time with my family
and which is great in terms of um seeing
friends at the moment
well i've got lots of friends at
university uh who have traveled back
the government haven't been very clear
of when we can go back to university so
pretty much all of my friends have
decided to pack their bags and just go
back
off their own accord and i'm video
calling a lot of them and catching up
it's not the same but it has given me an
opportunity to see some friends that
that live here in essex i went on a walk
with a good friend yesterday and
we can see each other face to face so
there are some positives to take out of
it but i'm missing a lot of people
okay we'll hopefully get to see more of
them soon josephine of course
acting and singing all about
collaboration and interaction
is that affected you a bit not been able
to do that or has the business
kept you busy well
uh on a personal level i've actually
suffered quite a lot of grief
um myself uh in the past year
um and as a griever i found this time
really really hard because
grief's a very lonely place anyway and
even when you're in a room full of
people so
in a time when we can't have our loved
ones there to hug
us and look after us it's been quite
difficult so my business has definitely
kept me going yeah
listen it's been fantastic talking to
your best and i
mean this most sincerely best of luck
for the future you are the future really
good talking to you all thank you very
much indeed